präsident denken sie
dass präsidentiellen ski ukrainisches
territorium abgeben muss um zu einem
waffenstillstand mit russland zu kommen
oder es das vom tisch und
musste russland aus sind g20
ausgeschlossen werden
zum letzten zum ersten oder zum letzten
das kommt auf die g-20 an ich habe die
möglichkeit angesprochen
indonesien und andere länder nicht
einverstanden und
ich denke
wir brauchen da
auch die möglichkeit dass die ukraine an
den dritten teil nimmt
also die ukraine muss im grunde an den g
20 treffen teilnehmen können was für die
erste frage nochmal
das ist natürlich eine entscheidung die
bei der ukraine liegt nichts zur ukraine
ohne die ukraine das ist das team in
verhandlungen und diskussionen würde ich
sagen
das sind
das licht bei den ukrainern und
denen die da verhandeln ich dazu kann
ich nichts sagen ccd abc bbc
sie haben es ganz deutlich gemacht im
konflikt das nicht wollen dass der
dritte weltkrieg ausbricht aber ist es
möglich dass dadurch dass sie das so
früh gesagt haben dass sie zu früh
direkte militärische
interventionen
ausgeschlossen haben würde dadurch
eventuell putin mutig dadurch dass sie
sagen zwar nicht probiert werden das
war's ich mich
und fassi mische waffen angeht wenn die
in der ukraine genutzt würden würde das
eine militärische antwort hervorrufen
[Musik]
das würde eine antwort eine
entsprechende antwort
herausfordern und was die nato und geht
die entscheidung muss wird dann fällen
und polen da sieht man ja welche
auswirkungen der krieg auf diese
billionen von ukrainern hat ihr land
verlassen könnte dass ihre antwort
verändern nein es gibt viele
kriegszonen ich war in kriegszonen und
habe viele flüchtlingslager gesehen
könnte letzten jahre alt ist es
schrecklich aber
was man dann vor allen dingen sieht sind
diese kleinen kinder kinder ohne eltern
die in diesen flüchtlingslagern leben
die flüchtlinge die
frauen die männer menschen der völlig
verloren sind man sieht dass ein starren
blick diesen ausdruckslosem blick
gottes willen wo bin ich hier was
passiert mit mir
das wird auf jeden fall mein versprechen
verstärken dass die usa sicherstellen
dass
wir eine große rolle spielen werden bei
dabei dass wir diese flüchtlinge
das diesen flüchtlingen eine heimat
geben das ist ja keine frage die polen
rumänien und deutschland alleine
umsetzen können das ist eine
internationale verantwortung die usa
sind führt in der völkergemeinschaft und
wir haben eine verpflichtung uns zu
engagieren um das leiden und den schmerz
von unschuldigen frauen und kindern und
männern zu lindern
denen die jetzt aus der ukraine kommen
und das gilt für diejenigen die jetzt
über die
grenze kommen und ich hoffe das hat auch
ein ende wieder ich hoffe ich sehe dann
doch nicht so viele leute die
rüberkommen
vielen dank herr präsident
eine präsidentschaftswahl kommt
und es gibt sorgen in europa das
eventuell jemand wie ihr vorgänger oder
ihr vorgänger wiedergewählt werden
könnte us präsident gibt es da
irgendwelche schritt oder etwas was sie
tun können oder was die nato tun kann um
zu verhindern dass das passiert
versuchen zu tun verhindert wird da
denkt aber nicht ich denke schon
länger als viele andere über
außenpolitik nach ich habe da kann das
sorge die ausführung mich aber ein
versprechen abgegeben
als sich diesmal zur wahl stand dass ich
nicht noch einmal als
präsidentschaftskandidat zur verfügung
stehen würde
und als ich diese
menschen sah dies sind eltern kam
die die gleichen stimmen leder sachen in
den anfang der 20er 30er jahren besser
gehen und diese nannten
sagte was meinen sie ein
demonstrant wurde getötet und das sagt
jemand
es wäre gäbe gute mannschaft beiden
seiten damals als diese
leute mittag kurz fragen da in den
südstaaten demonstrierten und als ich
das hörte da dachte ich das kann nicht
sein
ich habe mich
entschieden nicht keine
muss man das tun was richtig ist es ist
ja noch lange bis zu den nächsten wahlen
ein
gedanke bei wahlen ist dass wir
das haus und den senat den usa halten so
dass ich die möglichkeit habe sich das
tun kann was ich tun will also wachstum
wirtschaftswachstum
und
ich möchte eine nationale amerikanische
außenpolitik und ich möchte dass amerika
weiterhin die welt führt aber
ich sage immer zu hause stellen sich vor
wenn wir die szenen uns anschauen würden
wo die türen des bundestages
aufgebrochen werden wo die menschen da
reinkommen und mitarbeiter dort werden
getötet oder wenn das im britischen
parlament passieren würde wie würde uns
dann fühlen
der trost denn ich habe ist dass sie
wahrscheinlich keinen europäischen
führende politiker finden er denkt
dass ich den job nicht durchführen
könnte und ich finde das ehrlich es geht
jetzt nicht um mir selber auf die brust
zu schlagen
beim ersten
g7-treffen
1 wie hier war in großbritannien ich
habe damals gesagt
die usa sind wieder zurück und einer
meiner kollegen stadtchef seite für
bilal für wie lange also
ich kann niemanden
beschuldigen die frage zu stellen und
bei den nächsten wahlen wird wie freuen
wenn der gleiche mich noch einmal fragen
würde
danke
[Musik]
moment eine eine letzte frage seinen
letzten moment bitte
ich sollte eigentlich vor einer stunde
beim treffen der europäischen union
zahlen
ich bin ein clown also sehr
sind sie
abschreckend funktionierte nicht was
denken sie wird putins an hatten
verändern und ihrer maßnahme moment ich
habe nicht gesagt dass sanktionen ihn
abschrecken würden sanktionen schrecken
niemanden ab sie sprechen über darüber
sanktionen sind keine abschreckung
installationen werden genutzt um den
schmerz zu erhöhen und ich wollte das
nato treffen heute um sicherzustellen
dass nach einem monat vier
aufrechterhalten was wir tun nicht erst
im nächsten monat oder danach sondern
während des ganzen jahres dass wir den
stoppen
die etwas dazu führen dass er in der
ukraine etwas anderes tut und dann als
richtig gesagt die antwort ist nein das
habe ich auch nicht gesagt wir müssen
geschlossenheit das wichtige ist wir
müssen
geschlossen stehen
und die welt muss sich darauf
konzentrieren was für ein brutalo dass
ein mensch ist und wie viele unschuldige
menschen getötet worden sind wie viele
leben zerstört worden sind das ist das
wichtige wenn sie putin sind wenn sie
denken dass europa zerbricht in einem
monat oder sechs wochen oder zwei
monaten
die können alles aushalten für eine
weitere monat wir müssen aber zeigen und
deswegen wollte ich das treffen müssten
zeigen dass wir voll ständig geeint
bleiben danke
[Musik]
tja liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen beim zdf heute live
das war die pressekonferenz des us
präsidenten joe biden in brüssel wir
haben gesehen dass hätte noch viele
fragen der kolleginnen und kollegen
gegeben aber joe biden war der meinung
dass diese pressekonferenz nun beendet
ist einer der zentralen punkte ist dass
russland aus der g20-runde
ausgeschlossen werden soll das hat joe
biden gerade in den letzten minuten
gesagt es ist ein tag der in die
geschichte eingehen wird noch nie hat es
ein gipfeltreffen von nato geben und der
eu an einem tag gegeben an einem ort
nämlich in brüssel und das alles unter
der teilnahme eines amerikanischen
präsidenten nämlich joe biden darüber
möchten wir sprechen gerne mit ihren und
euren kommentaren wie immer in die
kommentare oder an die bekannte e mail
adresse und wir besprechen das alles mit
unserem korrespondenten vor ort el mati
wissen ist im
nato-hauptquartier in brüssel wenn ich
das richtig sehe wenn nicht dann
korrigieren sie mich bitte immer sie
haben die pressekonferenz im
pressezentrum in der nähe ok sie haben
die pressekonferenz aber mitverfolgt was
waren denn für sie die wichtigsten
erkenntnisse
ja ich glaube das was joe biden am
anfang und am ende einmal sehr sehr klar
gemacht hat dass es in allererster linie
um ein signal der einigkeit und der
geschlossenheit geht er hat ja gesagt
dass wladimir putin ganz offenbar die
usa und den westen die nato die g7 und
auch die eu unterschätzt hat und dass
genau das gegenteil von dem passiert ist
war sehr geglaubt hat er hat so sagt joe
biden offenbar geglaubt dass er die
europäer die verbündeten spalten kann
und genau das ist eben nicht passiert
und dieses signal der einigkeit will er
um jeden preis fortschreiben und vor
diesem hintergrund hat er eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen hier mit den
verbündeten besprochen dazu zählt allen
voran natürlich die hilfe und
unterstützung zum militärisch und
humanitär für die ukraine selber aber
auch für die staaten die betroffenen
sind durch die flüchtlingskrise er sagte
ganz klar man wird sie nicht im stich
lassen das ist eine internationale
verantwortung ländern wie polen wie
rumänien auch deutschland beizustehen in
den nächsten jahren und das gleiche gilt
auch für energiesicherheit er ist da
nicht in details gegangen aber wir
erwarten ja dass er morgen
wahrscheinlich dann mit der mit den
europäischen partnern vereinbaren wird
dass die usa flüssiggas nach europa ein
größerer menge liefern um defizite
auszugleichen wenn man tatsächlich
vielleicht sich ganz trennen kann vom
russischen öl und gas mir sind noch zwei
dinge ganz besonders aufgefallen das
eine ist die g-20 geschichte er hat
natürlich gesagt er ist der festen
überzeugung
russland darf an den g20 eigentlich
nicht teilnehmen er ist aber bei den
gesprächen heute ein stück weiter auf
widerstand gestoßen insofern gibt es da
keine hundertprozentige einigkeit nicht
mit den europäischen partnern sondern in
diesem fall mit indonesien das ist der
gastgeber des g20-gipfels im november in
bali und die indonesia wollen sich
neutral verhalten und haben deshalb eben
auch wladimir putin zu diesem gipfel
eingeladen mit joe biden hat gesagt wenn
das so ist das müssen am ende die g 20
gemeinsam entscheiden ob das so bleibt
aber wenn das so wäre würde er sehr
stark dafür plädieren dass die ukraine
auch eingeladen wird also teil dieser
beratungen ist das dürfte dann ein sehr
spannendes ereignis werden wenn der
stattfindet ich glaube das was noch
wichtig es ist vor allen dingen dass man
allen ländern die in irgendeiner weise
versuchen die sanktionen zu unterlaufen
zu unterminieren ein stückweit gewunken
hat dass sie selber ins visier von
sanktionen kommen allen voran china er
hat ja vergangene woche selber sehr
intensiv mit jinping dem präsidenten
gesprochen er sagt er hätte ihm nicht
gedroht aber ihm schon klar gemacht dass
die europäer und auch die amerikaner
wichtige wirtschaftspartner sind dass
die wirtschaftliche partnerschaft des
westens mit china viel wichtiger ist als
irgendeine was auch immer geartete
partnerschaft zwischen russland und
china also ein stück weit dann doch
gedroht dass es auch folgen haben könnte
und er hat angekündigt auch das ist eine
vereinbarung heute mit den verbündeten
das macht ja beobachtergruppe eine
taskforce einsetzen die eben genau
darauf achten soll wer unterläuft wie
die sanktionen des westens weil man will
sicherstellen dass jedes schlupfloch
geschlossen wird damit russland wirklich
auf die zahlungsunfähigkeit zusteuert
wladimir putin noch mehr zu hause unter
druck kommt dafür müssen diese
schlupflöcher geschlossen werden sagte
der präsident ja immer wir sehen hier
gerade die bilder von joe biden auch mit
nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg die einigkeit haben sie
gerade schon angesprochen und das wars
natürlich alle drei gipfel heute
versucht haben ist härte zu zeigen putin
etwas entgegenzusetzen einigkeit und
gleichzeitig auch diesen konflikt nicht
weiter zu eskalieren wie schätzen sie
das ein wie gut ist das heute gelungen
ja ich glaube schon dass sich die
verbündeten einig sind dass sie selber
jetzt nicht zu diesem zeitpunkt in
irgendeiner form in diesen trick
eintreten man ist auch relativ
vorsichtig bei dem was man an waffen
liefert man erkundet vor allen dingen in
eine option wie kann man der ukraine vor
allen dingen waffen zur verfügung
stellen die in der lage sind auf größere
entfernung russische ziele zu treffen
also zb boden luft raketen mit denen man
dann die russischen flugzeuge vom himmel
holen könnte ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt blome selensky hat ja heute auch
bei seinem auftritt bei der nato auch
bei den anderen auftritten die ja heute
hatte per videolink sehr klar
forderungen gestellt 10 prozent ein
prozent entschuldung 1 prozent der
bewaffnung der nato also der panzer der
flugzeuge das hätte er gern und das sei
die verpflichtung des westens und der
nato ukraine dieses zur verfügung zu
stellen aber da sind sich die
verbündeten weitgehend einig dass das
schwierig ist dass man nicht einfach
panzer soweit erreichen kann vor allen
dingen auch keine flugzeuge
island hat gefordert und einige andere
staaten dass man einen schritt weiter
geht dass man klar auch mehr
unterstützung gibt für die ukraine aber
ich glaube das risiko ist für die
meisten zu groß dass man dann als
unmittelbarer kriegsteilnehmer gesehen
wird und dass es dann zu einem großen
krieg kommt beiden wurde ja vorhin
gefragt ob es sind fehler war in den
letzten tagen und wochen immer und immer
wieder zu sagen wenn wir rein gezogen
werden wenn wir eingreifen in diesem
krieg dann droht der dritte weltkrieg
das hat er immer wieder gesagt und wurde
gefragt ob das ein fehler war weil man
damit ja putin signalisiert hat er kann
gewissermaßen machen was er will auf dem
boden der ukraine diese diskussion gibt
es auch in den usa sehr stark in der
politik in den medien in den
denkfabriken da steht der präsident auch
unter druck und ich glaube die nächste
hürde ist dabei die frage ob tatsächlich
in irgendeiner form
massenvernichtungsmittel biologische
chemische gleich gar nuklearen waffen
eingesetzt werden von der russischen
seite auf ukrainischem boden das wäre
eine art rote linie aber der präsident
das haben wir vor hingehört hat sich
geweigert klar zu benennen was dann
passiert hat aber auch nicht
ausgeschlossen dass das dann eine
eskalation sein könnte die auch die nato
zu einem weitergehenden ja ich sag mal
engagement verpflichtet ob das sein
kriegseintritt wer das hat er offen
gelassen genau das wäre meine nächste
frage gewesen wir haben heute gelernt
dass die allianz ihrer abwehr gegen
mögliche russische angriffen mit
chemischen biologischen oder sogar
atomwaffen aktiviert hat zum ersten mal
in der geschichte überhaupt und wir
haben boris johnson gehört dem
britischen premierminister der dem
russischen präsidenten barbarei
vorgeworfen hat und sagt zitat wladimir
putin hat schon die rote linie hin zur
barbarei überschritten also da ist das
wort rote linie schon verwendet worden
aber wie sie gerade ausgeführt haben
wofür die amerikaner die rote linie
liegt das wäre dann noch eine zu
definierende position
ja das ist so weil man will natürlich
auch nicht offen sagen was dann droht
weil man damit es einfacher machen würde
für wladimir putin zu kalkulieren lohnt
sich diese weitere eskalation mit was
muss er rechnen es gibt natürlich leute
die sagen er soll wissen was ihnen dann
droht damit er eben abgeschreckt wird
aber der präsident hat ja vorher sehr
klar gesagt sanktionen oder auch andere
maßnahmen dienen nicht in erster linie
dazu abzuschrecken sondern im grunde
raum so viel druck zu erzeugen so viele
nachteile zu erzeugen dass wladimir
putin vielleicht doch ein interesse
daran hat zu deeskalieren und irgend
eine andere lösung zu finden die nato
wird sich tatsächlich auf die bedrohung
stärker vorbereiten das bedeutet dass
entsprechende kräfte mobilisiert werden
dass vorsichtsmaßnahmen getroffen werden
für den fall dass die biologische oder
andere waffen eingesetzt werden und die
nato hat eben auch angekündigt dass sie
der ukraine und anderen staaten in der
region helfen wird um für diesen fall
dann auch gerüstet zu sein mit den
entsprechenden materialien die man
braucht natürlich will man um jeden
preis vermeiden dass es zu solchen
angriffen kommt und deswegen gibt man
zumindestens mal dass einige und sehr
klare signal dass dass der einsatz
dieser waffen eine rote linie wäre auf
denen dann ein hoher preis zu zahlen ist
in die details wird dabei nicht gegangen
nun ist dieser gipfeltag noch nicht zu
ende heute abend steht noch der
eu-gipfel an auch da wird joe biden
teilnehmen was ist von diesem abend noch
zu erwarten
es geht da vor allen dingen um eben auch
die humanitäre hilfe in wie weit die
europäer gemeinsam mit den amerikanern
in der lage sind die ja die krise die
flüchtlingskrise so muss man es nennen
eben abzufedern den menschen zu helfen
die usa haben ja angekündigt heute dass
sie 100.000 flüchtlinge auch in den usa
aufnehmen wollen wie genau das aussieht
und ob die zahl wirklich groß genug ist
angesichts eines so großen landes wie
den vereinigten staaten darüber wird man
sicherlich streiten können auf jeden
fall will man alle maßnahmen ergreifen
und den europäischen staaten zu helfen
der zweite punkt der glaube ich auch
wichtig ist ist man will energie
sicherheit herstellen das heißt es wird
morgen wahrscheinlich die vereinbarung
geben dass die usa für die nächsten zwei
jahre in form von flüssiggas
energielieferungen garantieren auch
kanada mit im boot diese lieferungen
eben garantieren an die europäer um
defizite auszugleichen wenn man sich von
der abhängigkeit von russland ein stück
weit oder auch ganz verabschiedet was öl
und gas angeht das wird nicht einfach es
ist zwar schon ein stück weit im gange
normalerweise liefern die usa etwa 30
prozent ihres gas an die europäer das
hat sich in den vergangenen wochen schon
verändert mittlerweile sind es 70
prozent die aus den usa an gas eben an
die europäer geliefert werden und das
hat funktioniert indem man lieferungen
die eigentlich für asien gedacht waren
umgeleitet hat das hat man mit den
partnern im asiatischen raum
abgesprochen aber das kann man natürlich
nicht dauerhaft so weitermachen also es
wird darauf ankommen wie man das
organisiert und dazu gehört eben auch
wie wird das gas denn dann eingefädelt
in das netzwerk in europa es gibt nur
wenige stationen in denen das möglich
ist zum beispiel in den niederlanden es
sollen neue stationen für flüssiggas
gebaut werden aber das dauert natürlich
seine zeit und der dritte große punkt
den wir mit den europäern besprechen
will wie kann man nahrungsmittel
sicherheit gewährleisten sowohl für die
europäischen staaten gerade die die
unmittelbar sowohl vom krieg als auch
von der flüchtlingskrise betroffen sind
mit anderen worten den ausfall des
sogenannten brot corps also der ukraine
und russlands was denen ja sehr viel
getreide geliefert wird wie kann man das
abfedern usa und kanada wollen vor allen
dingen ihre produktion von
nahrungsmitteln entsprechend auch nach
europa bringen dazu müssen auch einige
handelsbarrieren noch fallen also da ist
noch eine menge arbeit und viele
afrikanische länder oder in anderen
teilen der welt sind ja ebenfalls von
dieser nahrungsmittelknappheit betroffen
die preise schießen durch die decke es
fehlt eben an nahrungsmittel und da hat
der us präsident angekündigt dass er in
den nächsten jahren in den nächsten fünf
jahren elf milliarden dollar zur
verfügung stellen will um ebensolche
nahrungsmittellieferungen zu garantieren
das wird natürlich alleine von den usa
nicht ausreichend auch da müssen alle
verbündete an einem strang ziehen um die
folgen dieses krieges auch für andere
länder in der welt abzufedern
aber ich werfe mir gerade einen blick in
unseren chat und lese unter anderem bei
youtube walter gieselmann der schreibt
mein traum keine waffen keine kriege und
die menschen vertragen sich dem wenn wir
uns alle anschließen können nur leider
ist die realität da gerade meilen weit
von entfernt ich würde gern noch in
einer frage auf die flüchtlinge eingehen
joe biden hat er davon gesprochen dass
die usa 100.000 flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine aufnehmen werden haben sie auch
gerade schon angesprochen was ist das
für ein signal was sagt diese
größenordnung über die hilfsbereitschaft
der amerikaner an dieser stelle aus
ja ganz ehrlich gesagt ist ein land wie
die vereinigten staaten das reichste und
stärkste land der erde mit
hunderttausend flüchtlingen die es
aufnehmen will ich sag mal nicht vorbild
für alle anderen das sage ich jetzt mal
einfach so klar und sage auch gleich
dazu dass es meine persönliche meinung
weil es kommt noch dazu dass die 100000
ein stück weit auch eine mogelpackung
sind denn die usa haben eine obergrenze
für flüchtlinge beschlossen das ist auch
mit dem kongress in den usa so
vereinbart von
125.000 flüchtlingen pro jahr mehr nicht
für die nächsten jahre und heute wurde
in einem hintergrundgespräch auch genau
danach gefragt was heißt dass kommen die
100.000 flüchtlinge auf der aus der
ukraine dann quasi oben drauf sind es
dann eben
225.000 pro jahres aller welt die
amerika aufnimmt nein wurde gesagt das
wird ein stück weit angerechnet nicht
alle seien ja auch flüchtlinge da werden
familien zusammengeführt wo verwandte
beispielsweise in der in den usa bereits
leben von ukrainischen bürgern also das
ist ein stück weit kein übermäßig
starkes signal
so bewerte ich das jedenfalls aber es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass sich das
noch ändert weil um das zu ändern müsste
der amerikanische präsident mit dem
kongress darüber reden und ich glaube
bei den politischen parteien in den usa
den demokraten und den republikanern ist
tatsächlich die solidarität mit der
ukraine sehr stark sehr groß einige
fordern eben auch weiter zu gehen was
waffenlieferungen angeht und vor diesem
hintergrund gibt es chancen auch diese
zahl von 100000 noch einmal zu erhöhen
immer wenn wir zurückblicken in die
geschichte dann gibt es ein großes
beispiel dafür dass waffen frieden
gebracht haben nämlich die geschichte
mit dem ende des nationalsozialismus auf
die diese europäische friedens- und
sicherheitsrat nun ja am ende beruht die
durch waffengewalt damals erzeugt wurde
durch die alliierten durch den einsatz
fremder mächte die dem
nationalsozialismus und hitler hier ein
ende bereitet haben welche rolle spielt
das auch im bewusstsein derer die sich
da heute getroffen haben dass man
mitunter doch mit waffengewalt konflikte
beenden muss weil man diplomatische
lösungen nicht bis zum ende führen kann
oder weil sie keine aussicht auf erfolg
haben
ja ich glaube dass eine lehre die man ja
gezogen hat nicht nur aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg sondern wir haben auch seitdem
viele auseinandersetzungen
erlebte ich wie man die 90er jahre
erinnern in europa als mitten in europa
ein krieg tobte und auch nur
waffengewalt am ende dazu beigetragen
hat diesen krieg das war die jugoslawien
krise diesen krieg am ende zu beenden
aber das wichtig ist immer dass das
flankiert wird und sehr eng verwoben ist
mit diplomatischen maßnahmen also nach
wegen zu suchen wie man dann aus der
eskalation aus dem konflikt aus dem
krieg wieder herauskommt und dazu bedarf
es auf allen seiten
beteiligte die dazu bereit sind die auch
bereit sind kompromisse zu schließen
aber es spielt hier in europa eine ganz
große rolle was im zweiten weltkrieg
passiert ist übrigens besonders
vielleicht für die osteuropäischen
staaten die sich ja nicht einfach der
nato angeschlossen haben weil sie es ich
sag es mal salopp cool fanden jetzt zur
nato zu gehören sondern diese staaten
haben erlebt in osteuropa was es
bedeutet unter einem diktatorischen
regime zu leben und zwar eben auch in
der zeit nach dem zweiten weltkrieg im
kalten krieg als sie zum warschauer pakt
gehörten als russland beziehungsweise
sowjetunion damals die unter ihrer knute
hatten und freiheit meinungsäußerung und
all diese dinge verboten waren und diese
staaten haben sich entschlossen
nach dem ende des kalten krieges eben
mitglied der nahezu zu werden und das
aus dem grund dass sie angst hatten vor
den ich sag mal den nachfolgestaat der
sowjetunion und jetzt fühlen sie sich
bestätigt in ihrer angst das sendet ja
auch ein signal an staaten wie finnland
beispielsweise und schweden wie
überlegen ob es sinnvoller wäre teil
eines starken militärbündnisses zu sein
das war vielleicht in den letzten jahren
nicht so attraktiv die nato auch deshalb
weil amerika der eigentliche so hat es
joe biden jahr formuliert an führer der
freien welt ausgefallen war unter donald
trump im grunde die nato ein stückweit
gespalten hat auch andere bündnisse die
europäer gespalten hat und insofern war
die nato mit ihren streitigkeiten ihrer
sinnsuche wohin geht das eigentlich gar
nicht so attraktiv und hier ist jetzt
das beispiel das ist notwendig ist teil
eines solchen bündnisses zu sein
vielleicht nicht unbedingt ein
militärbündnis aber teil eines starken
bündnisses und deswegen
spielt das für viele hier eine rolle und
gerade die osteuropäischen staaten sind
der meinung die nato müsste eigentlich
mehr tun wenn man eine moralische
aussenpolitik vertritt und das tut ja
der amerikanische präsident stellt sich
die frage wie lang kann man erlauben
dass menschen abgeschlachtet werden dass
städte in schutt und asche gelegt werden
mitten in europa auch wenn ein staat
nicht teil der nato ist das ist das
große fragezeichen dass hier viele haben
aber mittlerweile interessanterweise
auch in den usa eine diskussion über
genau diesen punkt stattfindet eine
kurze frage noch zur diskussion in den
in den usa bevor wir auch gleich noch
mal in einem stück auf diesen tag in
brüssel blicken ausführlich es gibt ja
auch gegenbeispiele es gibt afghanistan
es gibt den irakkrieg es gibt den jemen
es gibt viele konflikte in denen sich
gezeigt hat dass die amerikaner und
amerikanische waffeneinsätze nicht das
gewünschte ergebnis gebracht haben sie
haben keinen frieden gebracht sie haben
keine demokratie gebracht inwiefern ist
denn die amerikanische gesellschaft
überhaupt für einen militäreinsatz einen
potenziellen militäreinsatz oder ein wie
auch immer geartetes engagement der
amerikaner in militärischer hinsicht
gar nicht also die umfragen sind da sehr
eindeutig die amerikaner die bevölkerung
ist der meinung dass man natürlich der
ukraine mit allen mitteln hilfe zur
selbsthilfe leisten muss auch waffen
liefern sollte vielleicht auch mehr als
man bisher geliefert hat aber dass die
usa selber nicht in einen krieg mit
russland sich reinziehen lassen wollen
die die lust auf ich sage mal kriege in
aller welt die ist den amerikanern
gerade in den letzten jahrzehnten durch
diesen ewigen konflikt in afghanistan
und den irak vergangen ehrlicherweise
muss man auch sagen dass immer der
glaube dass ein militärisches engagement
am ende zur freiheit und demokratie
führt eigentlich immer schon falsch
gewesen ist wenn man nicht entsprechend
diplomatisch und mit vielen anderen
maßnahmen sich überlegt mit welchen
plänen geht man denn in so eine in so
einem konflikt rein um dann am ende auch
wieder rauszukommen exit strategie nennt
sich das das haben viele amerikaner in
der bevölkerung vermisste in den letzten
jahren letztes jahr ein beispiel
afghanistan der abzug der aus sicht
vieler amerikaner die tan tisch erfolgt
ist durch diese regierung gesteuert also
es gibt keine große lust sich in einen
krieg in europa wirklich rein ziehen zu
lassen aber gleichzeitig die feste
überzeugung dass hier etwas im gange ist
nämlich eine veränderung oder
zertrümmerung der weltordnung wie wir
sie in den letzten jahrzehnten erlebt
haben dass amerika mit den
bündnispartnern stärke zeigen muss und
russland die stirn bieten muss weil wenn
sie das nicht tun dann am ende
möglicherweise auch andere sich ermutigt
fühlen können stichwort china ihre
machtinteressen weiter voranzutreiben
soweit unser usa-korrespondent elmar
theveßen mitgereist mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten nach brüssel
danke für den moment bleiben sie gerne
noch bei uns aber wir können gemeinsam
noch einmal auf den tag in brüssel
schauen der heute vormittag damit begann
dass der amtierende
nato-generalsekretär ians deutenberg
doch noch einmal in seinem amt bestätigt
werden bestätigt wurde er soll doch noch
einmal bleiben eigentlich hätte er im
herbst eine neue aufgabe übernehmen
sollen aber in diesen zeiten setzt die
nato lieber auf kontinuität gunnar
krüger fasst zusammen
kurz nach zehn die nato macht den anfang
in brüssel es leitet der neue der alte
generalsekretär slogan 30 staats und
regierungschefs den schallt partner in
kiew doch der gibt kein kompliment
zurück
die nato muss noch zeigen was sie tut um
menschen zu retten sie muss beweisen
dass sie das mächtigste militärbündnis
der welt ist die welt wartet auf euch
die ukraine wartet
mehr waffen hilfe leisten die mitglieder
einen waffengang als bündnis schließen
alle aus europäer und amerikaner
doch us-medien spekulieren blaupause für
die ukraine sei wieder syrien ein
chemiewaffen einsatz wie 2018 sei eine
reale gefahr eine rote linie für die
nato nur privat wir bereiten uns darauf
vor wir arbeiten daran aber ich nenne
heute keine roten linie in wirklichkeit
hat wladimir putin doch die rote linie
zur barbarei
ist überschritten
konkreter wird das bündnis bei der
selbstverteidigung kampfgruppen künftig
auch in südosteuropa schon jetzt 30.000
soldaten
ihre ständige präsenz verbietet
eigentlich ein vertrag doch dem endziel
russland mit dem krieg nun selbst die
grundlage
das ist die neue realität das neue
normal darum gibt die nato darauf eine
dauerhafte antwort und die lautet
abschreckung und verteidigung
der auch in dem die bündnispartner und
der westen waffen in die ukraine liefern
elmar theveßen ist uns zugeschaltet hier
fragt ein user namens joghurt über
youtube welche waffen werden jetzt
geliefert
jahre gehen die verbündeten nicht in die
details da wurde stoltenberg heute
nachgefragt auch einige andere der
führenden vertreter des westlichen
bündnisses makro johnson und auch beiden
sie wollten nicht in die details gehen
offenbar gibt es einen willen innerhalb
des bündnisses mehr waffen bessere
waffen zu liefern allen voran eben
boden-luft-raketen die weiterreichen mit
denen also die ukraine auch in der lage
wären die russischen flugzeuge auf
größere distanz hin zu bekämpfen aber
auch
aufmarschgebiet der russischen einheiten
daneben anzugreifen und da will man
nicht in details gehen weil man eben
auch nicht zu viel verraten will über
welche wege wird das transportiert von
wem kommt dass da will man die russen im
dunkeln lassen aber wir notieren heute
das selbst nicht ausgeschlossen ist dass
systeme wie die s 300 oder s400 das sind
solche boden-luft-raketen in den
nächsten wochen geliefert werden könnten
der türkische präsident erdogan wurde
danach gefragt heute morgen erging dann
schweigend weiter varus weil die türkei
tatsächlich s400 boden-luft-raketen hat
solche systeme hat von russland
geliefert das hat in der vergangenheit
zu großen streit innerhalb der nato
beigetragen und das wäre natürlich ein
twist der geschichte so nenne ich es mal
wenn ausgerechnet die von russland
gelieferten erst 400 raketensysteme dann
an die ukraine weiter gereicht werden um
russische truppen zu bekämpfen also es
gibt da keine details das ist natürlich
hoch brisant so etwas und deswegen
halten sich die anführer der verbündeten
sehr zurück el mati wissen vielen dank
für diese einschätzungen nach brüssel
und einen weiterhin interessant
verlaufenden gipfel abend ihnen vor ort
allen dankeschön fürs mitmachen und wenn
ich das richtig sehe dann können wir uns
jetzt gemeinsam anschauen wie die lage
in der ukraine
sich darstellt heute genau vier wochen
nach kriegsbeginn
das sind bilder die an kriegsgebiete
erinnern wie kirkuk im irak oder kuban
in syrien aber das hier ist mario pohl
in der ukraine in europa bis vor einem
monat vor dem angriff der russen lippen
hier 440.000 einwohner jetzt zahlreiche
angriffe später sollen es nur noch rund
100000 sein es sind unmenschliche
bedingungen sagen augenzeugen
es fehlen lebensmittel wasser
medikamente
das russische fernsehen zeigt wie pakete
verteilt werden kleine kartons mit einem
großen zelt drauf ausgegeben von
russischen soldaten ein zynismus des
krieges von den russen beschossen dann
von den russen versorgt angelina will
ihren nachnamen nicht nennen und steht
mit mann und baby in der schlange
sie haben uns ein wenig brot gegeben und
windeln für die kinder und wir haben
haferflocken für das baby bekommen
85 kilometer von maria poll entfernt den
bernd janz feiern die ukraine heute die
eigene marine denn im hafen brennt ein
russisches schiff es soll ein
landungsschiff seien die osk das schiff
mit dem die ersten russischen panzer vor
drei tagen an land gebracht wurden
nach kiew erst wenn die hauptstadt fällt
der präsident besiegt ist ist das
strategische ziel aus sicht der russen
erreicht nach einem monat hat das
verteidigungsministerium
1800 luftangriffe auf das ganze land
gezählt aus ukrainischer sicht werden es
täglich mehr weil sich die russen am
boden nicht durchsetzen könnten
unsere freunde haben in den letzten 24
stunden 250 luftangriffe geflogen 60
mehr als noch am vortag
ein monat krieg in der ukraine
das hat den menschen viel abverlangt
auch dass sie ihre angehörigen und
freunde in aller schnelle vor dem haus
dem wohnblock beerdigen müssen
und bei uns in der sendung ist jetzt
catherine klüver spruch hallo frau
klüver es wog ich hoffe sie können mich
hören dem lächeln entnehme ich dass das
der fall ist grüße sie sie ist
publizistin und politikwissenschaftlerin
beim global public policy institute das
ist eine unabhängige denkfabrik in
berlin und sie haben heute mit
verschiedenen anderen wissenschaftlern
und politikern ein statement
veröffentlicht einen aufruf darin
schreiben sie dass es moralisch
irrelevant sei dass die ukraine kein
nato mitglied ist sie sagen putin hat
den gesamten westen angegriffen und das
bündnis muss jetzt entschlossen handeln
dieser gipfeltag in brüssel geht nun
fast zu ende was sind ihre erkenntnisse
heute
dass die nato genau das umgesetzt hat im
grunde was wir auch gefordert habe in
unserem kurz artikel im tagesspiegel sie
haben darauf verwiesen wir wollten damit
zum ausdruck bringen dass die nato
wirklich das machen muss was sie sich
auf die fahnen geschrieben hat nämlich
zusammenhalten und die ganz interessante
komponente die wir jetzt gesehen haben
als der amerikanische präsident vor die
presse trat ist dass wir wirklich eine
amerikanische führungs kapazität in
europa erleben wie wir sie natürlich
seit einigen jahren nicht mehr hatten
wir hatten zwar natürlich auch
ankündigung america sei zurück aber dann
natürlich erst die sagen wir weil
amerikanischen außenpolitischen fehler
mit dem schnellen afghanistan abzug aber
jetzt wirklich eine führungsposition der
amerikaner wieder in europa denn das was
der präsident da auch von seinem podium
verkündet hatte in der pressekonferenz
die hilfe die humanitäre hilfe die hilfe
für europäische für die eu um
sie zu unterstützen und bei der
bewältigung der flüchtlingskrise die
eigene aufnahme von 100.000 flüchtlingen
aus der ukraine
wir erwarten morgen einen energie pakt
zwischen den amerikanern und den
europäern das ist also doch eine
erweitert gedachte transatlantische
zusammenarbeit wie wir uns das wünschen
in diesem schweren moment für den westen
aber eben besonders für die ukraine ich
sehe hier im chat bei youtube schreibt
willi wacker die waffenlieferungen sind
nötig da wird die ukraine die russen
aufhalten kann irgendwann geht russland
die luft aus dass zumindest der erste
satz den lese ich auch ungefähr
inhaltlich so in ihrem aufruf heute sie
sagen auch die nato muss alles tun um
das überleben der ukraine zu garantieren
wie weit kann die nato und sollte die
nato aus ihrer sicht dabei gehen
die nato plant ganz planbare schritte im
grunde genommen sie haben in ihrem
beitrag beziehungsweise hertie wissen
hat darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich
nicht alles deutlich gesagt wird aber
das was deutlich gesagt wird macht die
nato weiterhin zu einem sehr
berechenbaren in anführungszeichen
gegner für russland es ist aber auch
wichtig in der offenheit der
kommunikation das heißt die vier
zusätzlichen
schnellen einsatztruppe neben osten
europas die sind richtig und wichtig wir
unterstreichen dort noch mal dass in der
struktur dieser
also der erweiterung von enthält vor ort
präsenz dieser militärmissionen die nato
sich an ihre eigenen regeln hält dass
wir auch gesehen habe dass bei der nato
militärübung jetzt im norden europas die
nato sich weiterhin an die eigenen
regeln gehalten hat russland eingeladen
hat als ob server teilzunehmen und und
und das heißt die nato hat die
kombination aus waffenlieferungen aus
stärkung der östlichen flanke aus einer
klaren und deutlichen kommunikation aus
einer unterstützung des sanktionspaket
es positioniert sich also wenn es um die
frage der moral geht die nato und dem
sinne als broker und als einen verbund
nist das und das haben wir in der
pressekonferenz des amerikanischen
präsidenten noch mal gehört sie ja klar
auch die die schlimmstmöglichen
szenarien für sich plant also und am
reißbrett skizziert nämlich ein angriff
mit chemiewaffen mit biologischen waffen
oder eben im allerschlimmsten fall mit
taktischen nuklearwaffen
dann schauen wir uns mal an wie die lage
denn militärisch sich im moment in der
ukraine darstellt wir haben eine karte
vorbereitet die wir uns mal anschauen
können und hier sehen wir das von norden
her putins truppen schnell in richtung
vier vorgedrungen sind dann aber dann in
den vororten gestoppt wurden und auch im
süden von der annektierten halbinsel
krim aus und im osten sind die
russischen soldaten vorgerückt und haben
mehrere städte unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht aber der widerstand der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ist
ungebrochen zum beispiel sehen wir dass
die großstädte archiv und mario pohl
immer noch weiter hart umkämpft sind und
werden
frau gruber s book wenn man sich diese
karte anguckt und feststellen muss dass
viele elite militär experten sagen wir
sind quasi in einem stellungskrieg
gelandet im moment tut sich nicht viel
die russen machen überhaupt keine
geländegewinne wenn sie sich überlegen
was das bedeutet für den russischen
präsidenten in dessen kopf maniche sitzt
aber natürlich muss man sich
verschiedene szenarien durchspielen
haben sie die sorge dass die eskalation
dadurch weiter vorangetrieben wird weil
russland sich beim weil putin quasi so
frustriert ist dass er nächste
eskalationsstufe gezündet
man muss sich zumindest darauf
einstellen man muss sich darauf
einstellen dass es zu einem
zermürbungskrieg kommen könnte was
könnte das heißen also wir sehen
natürlich die anwerbung von ja nennen
wir sie wie sie sind schergen im
auftrags krieger wenn man so möchte in
syrien und in anderen teilen des nahen
ostens alle möglichen überlegungen
stehen jetzt scheint es für herrn putin
auf dem reißbrett inklusive eben die
androhung oder die die das hingeben so
einen false flag also dass man
signalisiert durch die propaganda es
gäbe in der ukraine chemiewaffen
biologische waffen einen zusammenschluss
von biologischen laboren et cetera et
cetera um quasi dem weg zu ebnen
zumindest auf der propaganda schiene
einem chemischen einen chemischen
angriff zu nutzen wir wissen von
forschern die sich besonders mit dem mit
der historie von tschernobyl
beschäftigen das allein schon da
russische panzer massiv den boden
auflockern und zwar quasi um
radioaktives material frei zu setzen
oder zu beginnen ist frei zu setzen um
auch solche methoden in dieser
auseinandersetzung zu nutzen wir müssen
davon ausgehen dass vladimir putin erst
mal alles versuchen wird was ihm in
anführungszeichen noch bleibt daher
bietet sich an das was wirklich die
kollegen in der nato und in den
verschiedenen außenministerien gerade
tun nämlich wirklich diese reißbrett
planung bis zum ende war es passiert
würde man zurückgreifen auf die
taktischen pläne der 80er jahre das ist
dieses prinzip des im juli ihre show des
deutschen das wäre natürlich für keine
wünschenswert nämlich eine taktische
nuklearwaffen mit einer taktischen
nuklearwaffen zu beantworten da arbeitet
der westen sehr schlau meiner meinung
nach sequenziert an anderen
möglichkeiten und das sehen wir eben
auch an diesem fünften sanktionspaket
der amerikaner an den schritten die wir
über die nächsten tage noch hören werden
an der lauten überlegung des
amerikanischen präsidenten russland aus
den g20 auszuschließen da für die
ukraine mit an den tisch zu holen alles
das sind die dinge die jetzt zeugen von
einer westlichen kreativität herrn putin
zu entweder zum umdenken zu bewegen
beziehungsweise ihn an einen tisch forst
zu forcieren weil die russische
wirtschaft dann und das und die
russische innenpolitik so in schnellster
zeit so brach liegen wird dass ein
rational denkender akteur sich doch dann
in diesem fall an den tisch setzen
müsste diana fragt vermeer wie wird die
nato sich verhalten wenn putin nun
wirklich chemie waffen einsetzt wird man
dann in die kampfhandlungen eingreifen
es sind es gerade schon skizziert aber
können sie nochmal ganz klar ihre ihre
einschätzung da skizzieren
meine prognose ist dass die nato alles
versuchen würde weiterhin mit dem den
russischen staatspräsidenten in seinem
aktionsradius einzuschränken ohne dann
zu versuchen einen erweiterten schlag
einer erweiterten kampf schlag zu
provozieren das heißt sie würden andere
methoden deutlich heraufschrauben bevor
sie quasi physisch in den kampf
eingreifen wir wissen auch wenn wir über
das steht das ganze thema
flugverbotszone nachdenken dass zum
beispiel natürlich wir die diese piloten
dient als erstes in das gebiet rhein
flügen quasi dem tod weil das wäre sehr
sehr schwierig moralisch zu vertreten
das heißt es werden alle anderen hebel
eingesetzt werden und wir haben heute
eben wie gesagt noch mal gehört als
gewiss geht an die goldreserven es geht
an die mitglieder der duma alles das
wird jetzt vorbereitet um diesen in
einem solchen letzten schritt quasi
vorzugreifen und zu sagen es könnte dann
für den russischen staatschef für seine
eigene bevölkerung deutlich enger werde
nun sehen wir ja das ist auch ein krieg
der bilder wir erleben den ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky der auf bislang
ungeahnte weise die welt informiert der
über instagram präsent ist der sich in
die parlamente dieser welt hinein
schaltet aus einer kriegssituation
heraus glauben sie wirklich dass wenn es
bilder von giftgas angriffen in der
ukraine geben wird das ist nur ein
bisschen mehr als 1000 kilometer von
hier entfernt und wir kennen die bilder
wir haben sie in syrien schon sehen
müssen glauben sie wirklich dass der
westen diese bilder sehen wird ohne mehr
zu tun als das was sie gerade
[Musik]
prognostiziert haben
ich glaube dass wir werden bilder oder
würden bilder werden die sehr schwer zu
ertragen sind habe ich weiß nicht wie es
ihnen geht mir gegen die bilder der
letzten des letzten monats schon
unglaublich nahe wie wir wdm
eingekesselten menschen in mariupol
tagtäglich am lebendigen leib quasi
gefoltert werden durch diese
durch diese bomben teppiche und durch
die zerstörung ihrer stadt vor ihren
eigenen augen dh es muss abgewendet
werden nach möglichkeit dass es zu einem
solchen angriff kommt es gibt auch noch
andere arten und weisen quasi existente
chemie stoffe im land zu sichern
beziehungsweise auch noch über experten
dann quasi abzusichern oder zumindest
festzustellen wie viel chemie material
ist im land gibt was man was hochgejagt
werden könnte in anführungszeichen wenn
die chemie materialien nicht überflogen
werden das kann natürlich das wäre dann
so ähnlich wie der serie angriff wie wir
es in syrien hatten es muss aber sehr
schlau abgewogen werden welches risiko
sie eingehen können und wollen denn es
kann natürlich sein wie gesagt in
nuklearwaffen kann man auch verschiedene
raketensysteme setzen auf intermediär
war auf intermediär raketen also auf
kurz und mittelstrecken raketen oder auf
langstreckenraketen die russen haben
diese hyperschall raketen er quasi für
sich nutzbar gemacht haben uns
mitgeteilt haben dem westen mitgeteilt
sie hätten sie mehrfach schon in diesem
konflikt benutzt als diese waffe im
sommer quasi öffentlich wurde dar und
sollten viele menschen im pentagon die
stirn denn so weit sind die amerikaner
und die nato in der entwicklung dieser
hyperschall waffen noch nicht also da
ist ein ziemliches gefahrenpotenzial dh
es wird eine sehr sehr schwierige
abwägung wie eine nato dann handelt und
was sie zum beispiel gelernt hat aus den
fragen aus der syrien katastrophe sagen
wir einfach so und und dem verfehlten
libyen-einsatz das werden die dinge
seien oder die fragen die sich jetzt die
kollegen in brüssel und im besten fall
auch in allen hauptstädten stellen sie
haben gerade die führungsrolle des
amerikanischen präsidenten ange sprochen
zu beginn unseres gesprächs wird und
nochmal in denen in die pressekonferenz
reihen die joe biden heute abend gegeben
hat und werden dann auch darüber
sprechen können wie denn die neu
gewonnene selbst das neu gewonnene
selbstbewusstsein in militärischer und
verteidigungs politischer hinsicht der
europäer aussehen könnte hören wir mal
rein
aber die nato war noch nie so eng
zusammengeschweißt wie heute putin
bekommt genau das gegenteil dessen was
er haben wollte als konsequenz dessen
dass er die ukraine einmarschiert ist
und diese einigkeit brauchen wir auch
mit der europäischen union und auch den
g 7
tja so weit also der us-präsident
freispruch auf der einen seite sehen wir
amerikaner auf der anderen seite haben
wir europäer gesehen dass wir in
afghanistan im letzten sommer noch nicht
mal in der lage sind einen flughafen zu
sichern ohne die hilfe der
amerikanischen militärs nun gibt es ein
offenbar neues selbstbewusstsein der der
europäer in militär politischer hinsicht
was erwarten sie da
es gibt vor allen dingen sehr schnell
sehr viel neue finanzielle ressourcen
und dass man einen 1 1 system nicht über
nacht umbauen haben so viel ist klar die
nato aber bleibt weiterhin auf
europäischer seite auch handlungsfähig
natürlich auch mit unterstützung
amerikanischer und kanadischer truppen
das muss man gleich dazu sagen aber die
tatsache dass auch andere
instrumentarien bei den europäern dazu
kommen sollen also dass alles was aus
dem instrumentenkasten seit 20 jahren
nur stückweise vorankommt in der
europäischen außen- und
verteidigungspolitik das soll natürlich
jetzt durch verschiedene neue
finanzinstrumente die die europäer zum
teil beim gipfel in der sie beschlossen
haben aber jetzt auch über die letzten
tage verstärkt haben deutlich ausgebaut
werden aber natürlich wird hier immer
noch mit den amerikanern gedacht und das
muss auch so sein denn wenn es jetzt
geht um die schnelligkeit der
der hin stellung wenn man so will oder
der der erbrachten waffensysteme auch
gerade weil es um transportflugzeuge
geht wenn es um
wirklich die bereitstellung geht da sind
die amerikaner immer noch die die
führende nation die tatsache dass so
schnell zusätzliche amerikanische
soldaten mobilisiert werden konnten über
deutschland dann in osteuropäische bases
verlegt werden können das können die
amerikaner immer noch schneller als die
europäer aber denn auch das was über die
letzten wochen passiert ist ist ein
quantensprung in der europäischen
verteidigungs und sicherheitspolitik das
muss behände weitergeführt werden und es
muss vor allen dingen auch in die
richtigen systeme umgesetzt werden und
das werden die nächsten monate und jahre
erst zeigen können
sagt kathrin kluba sprüche ich möchte
ihnen nicht vorenthalten dass der user
gerald teuchert feststellt dass der
bücherstapel neben ihrer tür noch recht
niedrig ist und wenn bin gespannt wie
hoch er ist wenn wir das nächste mal
miteinander sprechen das wird sicherlich
der fall sein vielen dank
vielen dank für heute abend kathrin
kluba struck für ihre einschätzungen und
bis zum nächsten mal danke ihnen sehr
und wer gerne kathrin blum spruch hat es
angesprochen
möglichkeiten gibt es noch einige die
die eu die die die der westen russland
entgegensetzen könnte unabhängig von
militärischem eingreifen stichwort
sanktionen und was es da bereits gibt
und was angedacht ist dass fassen wir
jetzt zusammen
dieses bild ist die wichtigste botschaft
des tages die großen industrieländer g-7
stehen zusammen im schulterschluss gegen
putin ich habe die g7 heute als einheit
wahrgenommen
zu allen gerade drängenden fragen die
weltweit zu beantworten sind
zusammenstellt einigkeit mit den großen
demokratien dafür hat sich joe biden auf
den weg nach brüssel gemacht im gepäck
hat er eher wenig weitere russische
personen und unternehmen kommen auf die
us sanktionsliste die verwendung
russischer goldreserven wird
eingeschränkt auch auf dem eu gipfel am
nachmittag zeigt sich noch mehr
sanktionen gegen russland sind kaum
möglich außer der größten dem boykott
von russischem gas und öl doch nicht nur
die deutschen sind zögerlich
die position ganz klar es wird mit uns
kein gas und kein öl embargo gegenüber
der russischen föderation geben das ist
derzeit nicht realistisch andere länder
sind bereit zum größten sanktions
schritt auch wenn sie abhängig sind von
russischer energie sanctions unsere
unternehmer sagen mir dieses embargo ist
notwendig wir müssen putin stoppen es
ist nur geld wenn du lebst wenn die
infrastruktur da ist kannst du das
wieder reinholen
ist bereit noch mehr sanktionen zu
beschließen das energiethema ist einfach
das wichtigste wenn es darum geht wie
putin seinen krieg finanziert
doch im moment ist unklar ob putin
überhaupt weiter energie liefert er will
rubel für sein gas die europäer sind
dazu nicht bereit
das was wir bisher erfahren haben läuft
darauf hinaus dass es überall feste
verträge gibt in der die währungen der
bezahlt wird auch teil des vertrags ist
und das ist ja etwas was dann auch gilt
und dann steht meistens euro oder dollar
am abend wird joe biden in dieser runde
erwartet ein eu gipfel mit us-präsident
das gab es zuletzt vor 20 jahren der
krieg lässt alle zusammenstehen
und darüber sprechen wir mit unserer
korrespondentin anne gellinek ebenfalls
in brüssel beobachtet denen auch jetzt
gerade noch laufenden eu gipfel eine und
bevor wir über die sanktionen sprechen
möchte ich noch ganz kurz auf was
eingehen was gerade über die agenturen
kommt nämlich die dpa meldet eine
reaktion aus russland und zwar die
sprecherin des russischen
außenministeriums wird zitiert russland
hat den aufbau von vier weiteren
multinationalen gefechts verbänden der
nato scharf kritisiert zitat jedes
argument ist recht um den gefährlichen
und die stabilisierenden kräfte aufbau
an der ostflanke zu rechtfertigen dass
also zu den geplanten aufstockung der
truppen an den
an der ostflanke und noch ein zitat der
sondergipfel in brüssel sei nichts
anderes als eine séance zu eigenen
gehirnwäsche gewesen die usa könnten es
nicht ertragen dass russland ein land
sei das selbstständig souveräne
entscheidungen treffen und eine
unabhängige politik betreiben könne es
war klar dass es eine reaktion aus
russland auf diesen gipfel geben wird
das hat man natürlich mit einkalkuliert
bei diesen drei gipfeln die heute
stattgefunden haben ja und das
entspricht ja auch dem was russland und
die sprecherin des außenministeriums
sondern der kreml sprecher in den
letzten wochen gesagt haben russland
sieht europa ja im unterschied zu
amerika was seine haltung zu europa
offenbar geändert hat in den letzten
paar monaten
russland sieht europa als ein konstrukt
was es nicht versteht russland versteht
nicht wie nationalstaaten sich
zusammenschließen können und
souveränität abgeben können für ein
größeres gemeinsames ziel und deshalb
zieht russland vor ist so zu sehen dass
die amerikaner natürlich die eu
dominieren und dieser gipfel an dem joe
biden jetzt bei 3 in drei formaten
teilnimmt ist natürlich aus der
russischen propaganda sicht der
schlagende beweis dafür dass die
europäer nach der pfeife der amerikaner
tanzen und sowieso nur das machen was
die amerikaner wollen dann sprechen wir
über die sanktionen und auch da soll ja
einigkeit ausgehend von den westlichen
bündnisses ob es nun die nato ist oder
das europäische bündnis oder die g7
jetzt hören wir aber heute dass vor
allem die östlichen länder polen zum
beispiel oder die baltischen staaten
mehr sanktionen fordern andere sind da
zurückhaltender gerade deutschland wegen
der abhängigkeiten vom russischen gas
wie hat man da heute die balance
gefunden zwischen den forderungen und
der zurückhaltung der anderen ja es gibt
ja schon seit längerem sozusagen die
antreiber bei den sanktionen das sind
nicht überraschend die
eu-mitgliedsländer die eine grenze in
der nähe russlands haben und die sich
bedroht fühlen von diesem ukraine
konflikt das sind die polen die balken
aber auch slowakei tschechien slowenien
die also sozusagen anrainer der ukraine
sind die sind die ganze zeit immer dafür
die sanktionen zu verschärfen schneller
zu ag schärfer gegen putin sich
aufzustellen und dann gibt es die länder
die sehr stark von energieimporten
abhängig sind dazu das land aus dem ihre
sendet deutschland und aber auch
österreich italien ungarn die slowakei
rumänien die sind alle von russischem
gas abhängig und sind deshalb für eine
sind zwar für auch für sanktionen aber
nicht für ein embargo für einen stopp
von energielieferungen aus russland da
gibt es verschiedene
fraktionen es gibt zum beispiel irland
die sind ganz stark für ein öl embargo
aber die importieren anscheinend ja auch
überhaupt keine energie aus russland
also da gibt es sehr verschiedene
fraktionen bislang ist die einigkeit
dadurch erhalten worden dass man einfach
vier sehr schnelle und starke und wie
kanzler scholz heute sagte sehr wirksame
sanktionspaket beschlossen hat die da
will man jetzt erst mal gucken wie wie
diese sanktionen wirken und scholz
wertete heute den vorstoß putins dass er
seine gasrechnungen künftig in rubel
bezahlt haben wollt will auch als beweis
dafür dass die sanktionen eben
schmerzhaft wirken und dass putin
versucht seine eigene währung die durch
die sanktionen ins trudeln geraten ist
versucht das irgendwie zu umgehen und zu
reparieren als zeichen eben dass die
sanktionen doch wirken an der stelle
würde ich gerne die userinnen und user
die sich im chat gerade so ein bisschen
auf abwegen befinden und über
abtreibungen diskutieren darauf
hinweisen dass das nicht das thema diese
streams hier ist sondern dass wir uns
sehr freuen über konstruktive fragen zum
thema ukraine konflikt eine einen
kommentar eines users denen ich jetzt
leider nicht mehr finde zielte darauf ab
dass die usa und großbritannien
angekündigt haben flüssiggas nach europa
zu liefern das ist zwar eine schöne
sache aber wie der user schrieb fehlt es
dafür an logistik es gibt überhaupt
keine terminals die diese schiffe
überhaupt
versorgen könnten oder annehmen könnten
das hört sich natürlich erstmal nach
einer tollen lösung an aber das ist
natürlich in der gesamtschau auch keine
richtige alternative oder also es ist
vielleicht erst mal kurzfristig eine
lösung die ersatz schaffen kann für das
pipeline gas und öl aber bestimmt dass
deutschland keine flüssigkeit kein
flüssiggas terminal bis jetzt hat aber
europa hat natürlich jede menge
terminals ich glaube es sind über 20 an
den europäischen küsten ganze europa
herum und deutschland ist dabei zu
versuchen das los zu buchen in rotterdam
in
den französischen terminals überall wo
es möglich ist
aber natürlich ist das darüber wird in
letzter zeit relativ wenig gesprochen es
ist auch eine sehr sehr teure lösung
denn natürlich bekommen wir das gas was
wir langfristig aus russland bestellt
haben zu sehr viel geringeren preisen
als das flüssiggas was jetzt auf dem
weltmarkt preis verkauft werden soll
morgen will joe biden sich mit der
kommissionspräsidentin morgen vormittag
nochmal treffen und biden hat
angekündigt dass er dann noch mal eine
flüssiggas offensive starten will
offenbar ist man sich einig geworden
über weitere lieferungen aus amerika die
sozusagen europa darauf stupsen sollen
zu sagen guckt mal wir helfen euch dabei
vom russischen fossilen gas und öl
abzuwenden und wir wollen ja auch was
machen damit ihr andere energie bekommt
aber natürlich kann das flüssiggas
rechnerisch nicht schnell die russischen
importe ersetzen eine letzte frage noch
frankreichs präsident marco hat heute
vor einer beispiellosen
lebensmittelkrise gewarnt und auch us
präsident joe biden hat das angesprochen
dass die ukraine als kornkammer
natürliche länger dieser krieg dauert
ausfällt und das zu einem weltweiten
problem wird wie reagiert die eu darauf
also die eu hat das thema bearbeitet das
thema schon
seit einer weile das ist so ein bisschen
unter dem radar geflogen einfach weil
die kriegshandlungen natürlich erstmal
an erster stelle stehen aber es stimmt
die ukraine ist ein sehr sehr großer
lieferant für weizen und für andere
getreide und auch russland im übrigen
wir importieren üben auch aus russland
getreide das würden wir wahrscheinlich
im moment nicht machen wegen der
sanktionen und bei der ukraine besteht
die berechtigte furcht dass die nächste
ernte nicht ausgesät und schon gar nicht
geerntet werden kann also das ist ein
riesenproblem
man versucht jetzt jetzt schon über
verschiedene programme ersatz zu
schaffen
nordafrika ist ein problem die werden
als erste darunter leiden man versucht
sozusagen ersatz zu schaffen finanzhilfe
zu leisten die ströme umzulenken aber
noch ist das ausmaß nicht ganz klar und
deshalb weiß man noch nicht genau wie
man darauf reagieren kann vielen dank
anne gellinek nach brüssel für diese
einschätzungen heute abend und damit
verabschieden wir uns hier an dieser
stelle vom livestream wenn sie das thema
weiterhin mitverfolgen wollen dann
können sie den fernseher einschalten
denn bis viertel nach acht läuft noch
unser zdf spezial kasse können sie sich
natürlich sehr gerne anschauen heiße
empfehlung hier von uns und natürlich
sind wir wieder bald für sie da zu
diesem oder zu einem anderen thema aber
ich mutmaße zu diesem dort ist sein
leider gottes ich danke ihnen sehr für
ihre teilnahme und fürs zuschauen bis
bald